وليد قصه هذه الرضيعه الفلسطينيه التي
اخذت من قطاع غزه وماذا عن التحركات
السياسيه نتوقع اجتماعان اليوم لنتنياهو
قضيه هذه الرضيعه فيها من الغموض اكثر مما
تكشف وضع قصتها انفضحت عندما كان احد
الجنود يحاول امتداح ضابطه الذي قتل فيما
بعد وهو يتحدث كان هذا الجندي يتحدث
لاذاعه الجيش فحاول ان يظهر كم كانت
انسانيه ذاك الضابط قال بانهم عندما كان
قد دخلوا الى احد المباني سمع في مدينه
غزه سمع هذا
الضابط بكاء رضيعه فاخذها ولم يكن هناك اي
شخص اخر كان جميع من حولها قد قتل فاخذها
وقال بانه فيما بعد نقلها الى اسرائيل لكن
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي حولنا الاستفسار
منه قال ان لا علم له بمثل هذه القصه وانه
يحقق مع مصدرها بمعنى مع الجندي الذي تحدث
للتاكد منها مصادر اخرى حاولت القول بانه
تم بعد ذلك وفورا تسليمها الى وكاله غوث
اللاجئين الانروا لكننا لم نتمكن من
الحصول على رد من الاونروا ولا من
اليونيسيف بهذا الخصوص هذه القضيه مثار
جدل واسع كيف ان هذا الضابط الذي قتل فيما
بعد حمل هذه ال ضيع معه من غزه كيف اخرجها
وكيف اخذها الى داخل اسرائيل والى عائلته
وكيف تمت اعادتها وبقي الموضوع طي الكتمان
مساله جاءت في محاوله من جانب جندي كما
قلت لاظهار انسانيته لكنها جاء في وقت
ايضا تكشفت فيه ابعاد معسكر الاعتقال الذي
اقامته السلطات الاسرائيليه سرا في منطقه
تعرف باسم ديتي مان في عمق صحراء النقب
وتحتجز به اعدادا كبيره من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الغزيين الذين جلبتهم من غزه
وهؤلاء محرومون من كافه شروط الحياه وايضا
يتعرضون للتنكيل ول الضرب بشكل مبرح من
قبل الجنود الذين قالت هارتس نقلا عن مصدر
مطلع بان الاعتداء عليهم ينفذ كل جند جندي
ما يحلو له ضدهم ويقومون بضربهم وهم
معصوبي الايدي ومقيد المعاصي ومربطين في
جدران وانهم لا تتوفر لهم حتى شروط الحياه
البسيطه للمنامه والاكل وغير ذلك واعدادهم
مجهوله والمكان ايضا هذا المعتقل السري
مجهول لكن يضاف الى ذلك
بان عدد المواطنين الفلسطينين من قطاع غزه
الذين اعتقلتهم قوات الاحتلال ونقلتهم الى
داخل اسرائيل قد ارتفع الى
150% عما ما كان عليه بدايه الشهر الماضي
واصبح الان نحو
660 معتقلا موزعين على عدد من السجون لكن
معظمهم في معتقل كت سعوت في جنوبي النقب
والمعتقلات من قطاع غزه نقلنا الى معسكر
عتوت الموجود في شمال شرق مدينه القدس
المحتله وفق صحيفه هارتس هذه المواضيع
مثار جدل متزايد سواء من خلال التنكيل
والتصرفات او من خلال قصه تلك الرضيعه
الذي فيها من الغموض الكثير والحكومه
الاسرائيليه اليوم من المفترض ان تعقد
جلستين يراسه ما نتنياهو لمجلس الحرب
وكذلك للمجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر
الكابينت المخول باتخاذ القرارات
والمصادقه عليها لكن هذه القرارات يبدو
انها ستبحث بدايه في مجلس الحرب